Selena Gomez and Demi Lovato reunite and
our hearts are bursting it's amazing
the childhood pals who met on the set of
Barney and Friends and went on to
co-star in the 2009 Disney flick
princess protection program surrounded
yourself with the greatest girls had a
sweet reunion on Monday night
I'm really excited posing together and
looking ultra glam at the InStyle Awards
in Los Angeles ain't is feel really
blessed Gomez looked chic in a sexy
black mini dress while Lovato slayed in
a lilac Alice and Olivia gown with a
thigh high slit and belted waist the two
haven't been seen together in years I
think people are gonna be a little
surprised but fans freaked out over a
few friendly exchanges on social media
in July Lovato tweeted quote at Selena
Gomez loving your new song fetish we've
come a long way since our Barney days
[Music]
gomez sweetly responded yes we have just
listening to sorry not sorry
you slay as always so happy for you
[Music]
the bad liar singer also commented on
Lovato's Instagram after her YouTube
documentary simply complicated was
released writing quote this was
beautiful I'm so happy for you you
always continue to be bold and real I
wish more people were like you love you
[Music]
you
[Music]